perfetto prima o poi inventeranno anche
gli enti così io aspetto solo quel
giorno è l'asset di ragazzi e benvenuti
a me sono video sano valigia e oggi
siamo tornati sul shop simulator che non
facevo da una vita
tra l'altro siamo tornati ragazzi perché
non avevo finito assolutamente di fare
store clerc che sarebbe quello di fare
il commesso al supermercato due truffe
non si siano superati i vini devi stare
zitto facciamo energize serve allora
facciamo finta di fargli fare i commessi
e l'esselunga sono un commesso nano
l'unica cosa che sapevo dello store
checker era questa che prendendo
stoppato prendendo sta cosa
giriamo la roba di sotto così e siamo a
napoli il prefetto perfetto porca [ __ ]
con rpg entra qualcuno perché non hanno
fatto anche il parrucchiere dove ci si
divertiva al akhbar va bene ragazzi
allora possiamo cominciare andiamo niamo
ticket vai col ticket
io spero di non buttare giu salve stai
facendo jogging
devo farti qualcosa per energizzanti non
mettere in frigo ragazze st savoia che
vuoi una monster altro passare
giustamente sono fugati ok ai soldi
grazie grazie di dio perfetto grazie dei
big money top che tu ad aregai tra è
comprata prendi della ok non regala cosa
che volevo vedere ma non è che tipo
lo sapevo io lo sapevo gioco dell'anno
coca cola mentos e nutella record del
mondo ma [ __ ]
no non ci posso credere non ci posso
credere ma veramente next ticket ma il
carico salve
queste azioni a voi che ti dia delle
cose a caso ma crosa il mio mondo dello
snowboard fantastico
tieni questa tela regalo ti regalo anche
insieme alla maionese abbiamo bellissimo
libro botman scritto da ciccio gamer
tieniti puoi comprare dei soldi ti puoi
comprare dei soldi se hai dei soldi puoi
comprare un mezzo pezzo di formaggio
non lo so cosa sia proprio mezzo va ben
altre cose che puoi comprare anche il
commesso commesso gratta e vinci così
diventi ancora più ricco tanto non si
vince un cazzo bene che puoi comprare
anche questo bel cappello che provi me
ecco qua per questo è perfetto per
l'acquisto io aggiungerei addirittura
una bella pippa che tieni il pane per il
virus del prefetto veloci a comprarlo
veloce e finisce esci veloce dal da qua
grazie ad i soldi tanti soldi big money
da 6 gradi ed esci velocissimo però
veloce
grazie per essere passato torni a
trovarli non troppo presto per maghetto
harry potter
ciao allora non capisco un cazzo di
collocamento spazi confuse prendiamo i
wurstel tiene hanno gelato poi leccati
steve uster surgelati cazzo fai a
scandiano tieni a voi i soldi in cambio
ti devo dare i soldi io io che ti dò le
cose voi anche i soldi ma ecco le monete
ex prego mi dai sodio non ami degli hare
soldi ha tratto è sbagliato uscire
perché l'uscita di latte deficiente e
scemo questo ma non puoi darmi i miei
soldi per comprare il mio robot e gli ho
dato io devi darmi dei soldi in cambio
questo arresto quindi mi devi dare più
soldi di quelli che ti dò io su questo è
un resto gli del 5 euro almeno che è in
noi che vietino arresto e poi fa il giro
e torni compri le cose
coi soldi che ti ho dato io sei un
[ __ ] in questa nuova la candeggina
se vuoi veramente la candeggina va bene
è vera figata ragazzi questo rispetto
agli altri grave è il più bello non so
perché veramente figo
ce n'è anche una camicia hanno rapinati
già prima per favore non faccia
stronzate almeno miliare una banconota
almeno lei ma mi scusi eh adesso vedo
tutto l'incasso della giornata ma se io
per per caso volessi a cena in un altro
allora no e allora sì che sono nella
merda la cassaforte non la so io aprire
pronuncio il codice a ok riapre la
società si è proprio sicuro di volere
questi oggetti di valore
allora questo questo è il grana è il
miglior antiossidante al mondo ancora ma
con quello sei a posto tutta la vita
cosa vuoi di più così te ne fai di tutto
il suo valore
vuoi addirittura inler banner il
galbanino hai detto ma tu sei tu scemo
[Musica]
basta che te ne vai grazie ci hanno
rapinati dei formaggi grazie al mio
prossimo ci hanno rapinati già due volte
non c'è due senza tre nomi sono le già
ubriaco e lo sapevano i due sub sono
sono qui sono qui io qui quindi sono mi
vede mi ha visto sul serio pulito
gigante si fa così
ok vieni e tutto tuo nel sacchetto che
igienico ben nicchia 5 euro di burrito
fai te da mister ora che ci rapine o dio
grazie ad una vita e mezza per
pareggiare dei soldi dai da statina che
lavora il primo che mi pagano altro po
quanti problemi questo negozio e vabbè
chi siete voi siete minorenni vi vedo
che siete minorenni nostro sì io non
vivendo la birra non posso sede
minorenni schifosi dammi la carta
d'identità velluto deficiente non ti
credo
eccola questa carta in 100 per cento
reale nome adulti bot anni abbastanza
carta identità totalmente legale
per me ha posto zio che non si intuiva
lux a voi avete volete comprare i fuochi
d'artificio hanno capito la tieni non
fate casino ma sono le superchicche
aspetta il cappello il caffè è stato
beppe cao però ciò degli high di falsi
wikia possono scappare in messico
io non ambula la sinistra deve
identificare il sospetto tra questi 3 ma
ce l'avete lì vabbè comunque lui non mi
ha dato i soldi ce n'era uno che prima
che non ha pagato prova rivede che basta
non essere ciechi si vede un sound cosa
prima visto ragazzi il cappello e
cappello porca [ __ ] tracciabili 20 col
cappello prima di finire grato solo
gratta e vinci
mi tocca calorico va affatto youtube
palais ragazzi basta è stato fighissimo
stato veramente figo chiude il solito è
vissuto e figo ma non così figo ma lei
ragazzo linee che possono pure qui video
spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa anche per
i social coniglio iniziale se decidiamo
noi